abend urlaub land präsentiert vorkommt
die krise ein spezialist für den ort
konnte krieg punkt ch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fünf tage 200 km bis minus 20 grad
mit dem husky gespann quer durch die
wildnis lapplands
vier frauen und ein mann erfüllen sich
einen traum
20 stunden dunkelheit am tag eine reise
die sie an ihre grenzen bringt aber auch
ihr leben verändern wird
es ist schon eine sehr große bereiche
gibt es jetzt sich prägen
worum es
genau da auch nicht
wahnsinnig innerhalb von vier tagen
bin ich jetzt erlebe
fünf tage zuvor das abenteuer startet
100 kilometer nördlich des polarkreises
auf der husky ranch von julie psa im
finnischen kotka co
es ist anfang dezember 2009 10
gemeinsam mit seiner frau hanna betreut
joho hier 29 alaskan huskys
hanna wird in den nächsten tagen auf die
ranch aufpassen müssen ihr mann jo wird
mit den schweizer abenteurern unterwegs
sein
ich meine ich würde es lieber ein
bisschen kälter aber ich bin zufrieden
dass die seen gefroren sind die eis oder
schneeschicht ist immerhin 40 cm dick
die trails sind wirklich gut dass es
nicht selbstverständlich für diese
jahreszeit
judo und hanna haben seit 2009
schlittenhunde euro für zwei bis drei
langstrecken rennen pro winter mit ihnen
doch meistens ist er in dieser
jahreszeit touristen unterwegs
fünftägige touren sind aber eher selten
die schweizer gruppe ist unterdessen in
der dunkelheit lapplands angekommen die
vier frauen und ein mann haben sich bis
jetzt nicht bekannt
eine hr managerin eine physiotherapeutin
eine software test managerin der
brunnenmeister aus giswil und eine
psychologin und mutter von drei kleinen
kindern
[Musik]
sie haben sich auf einen aufruf von sf
dok gemeldet was sie verbindet der
wunsch für fünf tage aus ihrem alltag
auszubrechen und die liebe zu hunden und
so natura platz
bevor es losgeht eine letzte nacht in
einem warmen bett
am nächsten tag statt schnee und
minustemperaturen
heute sollte die tour beginnen
[Musik]
so hat alles vorbereitet
oma
ihr seid also meine gruppe hallo
willkommen auf der husky grange ich
wünschte wir hätten besseres wetter
ich weiß ihr wollt die hunde treffen
aber zuerst werden wir euch bessere
und dann werfen wir einen blick auf die
karte wo wir in den nächsten fünf tagen
unterwegs sein werden den reihen der
regen ist schrecklich
habt ihr so was schon gemacht wie viel
erfahrung hat hier keine erfahrung keine
erfahrung
halb tagestouren
okay die schönen die einfachen die mache
ich normalerweise auch
tagestouren
eine einstündige tour ok also wenigstens
ein bisschen erfahrung
das ganze ist einfach wenn der hunde
liebt und die natur dann ist das schon
mal ein guter start und
denkt daran wir werden weit fahren
deshalb müssen wir als team zusammen
bleiben du darfst das team nicht
verlieren punkte
wir fahren zuerst fünf kilometer durch
wald dann kommen wir in dieses große
naturreservat das größte sumpfgebiete
ruppert
[Musik]
die tour beginnt 100 kilometer nördlich
des polarkreises in finnland von kurtág
führt sie am ersten tag 35 km durch das
größte sumpfgebiet europas in die wälder
platz am zweiten tag folgen 46 kilometer
am dritten tag weitere 38 kilometer mit
dem steilen anstieg auf den alle story
und am vierten tag folgt die
königsetappe mit über 50 kilometern den
gleichen weg zurück
bevor es am fünften tag wieder zur reds
geht
[Musik]
inzwischen hat es aufgehört zu regnen
die teilnehmer lernen ihre hunde kennen
alle sind nett er könnte überall
hingehen keiner weiß
das wird ein hund sein silvia er wird
direkt vor dem schlitten laufen erst
stark may day wird in der mitte sein
das ist die mutter von medi die schwarze
erde
ich werde sie nicht ins erste team
nehmen sondern irgendwo in der mitte
[Musik]
sie wollen nur noch los das ist für sie
ein zeichen zum aufbruch
wenn leute in dieser kleidung her stehen
mayday ist erst einjährig und war noch
nie auf einer so langen tour
der brunnenmeister den großen starken
[Musik]
marien und spieler kennen ersparen indem
man gab es für biberschäden tief
gedrückt
charaktere
[Musik]
jede und jeder wird während der tour für
sein eigenes gespann mit fünf hunden
verantwortlich sein
zuerst heißt es schlitten packen mit
essen für sich und die runde dem eigenen
gepäck und dem camping material jeder
schlitten wiegt so bis zu 60 kilo sie
bekommen erste instruktionen auf der
farm denn auf der tour müssen sie die
hunde versorgen camps aufbauen und vor
allem die kontrolle über das gespann
nicht verlieren
wir gehen die fahrer instruktion durch
wenn wir unterwegs sind gibt es drei
einfache zeichen
dass hier heißt langsam
ihr bleibt mit dem fuß auf der bremse
platte das heißt stopp steht auf die
metall bremse und wenn wir angehalten
haben müsste auf der bremse bleiben
wenn die pause länger ist dann setzt
hier sogar den brems anker aber auch der
held nicht sicher auch wenn wir anhalten
behält ihn im auge
und wenn ihr runter fällt so
was passieren könnte
das passiert immer wieder
wenn er also runter fällt und hier hängt
lässt nicht los das ist die wichtigste
reden lasst den schlitten nicht los
wartet bis die hunde anhalten steht
wieder auf die bremse
atme tief ein und fahrt weitere
kleider ab dann wird niemand wissen dass
er unter gefangen sein
wir spannen zuerst die lieder ein und
denkt dran diese kleinen kreaturen
werden die seile durch beißen wenn er
nicht aufpasst
also schaut immer wieder dass die hunde
noch da sind
[Musik]
die schwarze dahinten
armin dass die hunde nicht raus
[Musik]
sie in das geschirr im zwinger an und
kommt mit einem hund ins öffnen ich die
türe sonst rennen sie rausdrängen sie
zurück
[Musik]
kaum sind die runde eingespannt wollen
sie losrennen
so versucht alles unter kontrolle zu
behalten
[Musik]
dann endlich euro' gibt das zeichen für
den start der tour die reihenfolge ist
klar definiert jeder hat seine position
doch ausgerechnet mich die früher
professionell bob vor kann ihre hunde
nicht mehr zurückhalten erlöse deine
bremsen nicht zu früh kontrollierten
team ständig auf die bremse
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann endlich geht es los es ist 12 uhr
dollar
und sie sagen bis der anständig ist im
herbst geplant
[Musik]
und da ist es das gefühl von freiheit
davon haben sie alle geträumt
eine stimmung
speziell
mystisch
[Musik]
die tage im dezember sind kurs nur vier
stunden dämmerlicht schon nach 2 uhr
verschwindet das licht noch bevor die
dunkelheit hereinbricht ein erster stopp
essens pause auch für die tiere
wie geht es dir gut
15 kilometer haben wir schon
mittagspause
auf silvia wird euro' ein auge werfen
vor vier jahren bekam sie die diagnose
parkinson die tor stellt für sie eine
besondere herausforderung dar
dank medikamenten führt sie ein
weitgehend normales leben ihr arzt gab
grünes licht für die tour
pass auf dass die hunde nicht deine
leine durchbeißen
kannst du uns bitte helfen
dass sein muss einige male um dann der
knoten noch klappt nicht alles
sei vorsichtig mit den fingern sie
lieben diese brüste
die hunde erhalten ein stück gefrorene
wurst
[Musik]
viel arbeit an die sich das team noch
gewöhnen muss
[Musik]
die hunde wollen weiter zurückgelegt
haben sie erst den halben weg keine
distanz für sie
[Musik]
silvia erfüllt sich mit der tour einem
traum wegen der fortschreitenden
krankheit weiß nicht wie lange solche
abenteuer für sie körperlich noch
möglich sein werden
[Musik]
es ist zwar erst 15 uhr doch schon
stockfinster
alle ahnen dass noch einiges auf sie
zukommen wird
[Musik]
armin der brunnenmeister macht den
schluss in der schlitten kolonne seine
hunde sind die kräftigsten aber auch die
wildesten
nach drei stunden fahrt gegen 17 uhr das
erste nachtlager mitten im wald
her sind wir
eher ist es schön
sucht euch alle einen baum
doch einer fehlt armin
glaube sich irgendwie
armenische mir ich glaube eben lehrstoff
falsch war und der shop
zum glück passierte der fehler so nah am
etappenziel so hat jo armins gespannt
schnell gefunden
nun beginnt die arbeit in
der szene
gehabt wo nie gewusst zu haben ein
bisschen buchhandel wurden zwecks
nachzug
[Musik]
ballack
jeder hund sucht sich sein eigenes
plätzchen
das bett und sie hätte was
bewegt sie
präpariert den hunden haupt geschlossen
das fleisch ist noch gefroren und musst
du erst aufgetaut werden juhu
kontrolliert alles journal of sports
die kiste muss voll wasser sein
zuerst kommt das fleisch rhein etwa zwei
drittel voll
dann füllte es bis oben mit heißem
wasser auf sonst wird das nicht weiß
[Musik]
gibt es ruhig auch den großen jungs
und wenn ihr ihnen das essen hinstellt
passt auf
kommt von einer seite
perfekt
abenteuer lappland es bedeutet nicht nur
romantik sondern viel verantwortung erst
gegen 21 uhr kann sich auch die gruppe
verpflegen
ja ich
nicht mehr so sicher
ob das so kommt und ich bin überzeugt
dass wir besser als der staat muss ich
finde meint dass jetzt merkt aber
sachen der super klappert haben reich im
griff und dem ist auch enorm steigern
und dann doch bitte hin und her läuft
man sie sind eine echte kronzeugen diese
die ganze spannung und freude und und
und also irgendwie den richtig emotional
sehr emotional so dass alle segel nie so
die freut dass alles erlaubt ist
besteuerung
wegen notorischer was mache ich jetzt
irgendwie so was mache ich jetzt erhöhen
das mache ich jetzt mit dem gepäck und
so deswegen ist unser pcgh
hilfloser mit gefühltem erfahrung aber
bleibt das coni sah wieso der nächste
tag das sind dann weiß man muss machen
wir machen das richtig machen
flo und ich so gut oder so schön aus
jeder angst
dass sie neben aktie habe aber
ich war sehr beeindruckt mit dem
gemeinschaftschor ich habe mein team
gefüttert und dann habe ich gedacht soll
ich hingehen und ihnen sagen sie sollen
das zelt aufstellen aber es war schon da
das füttern müssen wir noch ein bisschen
verbessern
da ist noch unsere schwachstellen aber
für das zelt gibt es schon mal 5
es gibt diese heilige regel dass man
nicht ist bevor die hundefutter halten
sie haben das nicht gerne und werden
dich nicht mehr mögen
[Musik]
es ist morgens um halb sieben die nacht
war kalt
[Musik]
kaffee tee
die hunde warten bereits hungrig auf ihr
fressen doch die abenteurer nehmen es
gemütlich zum missfallen von yahoo
die rufen war zwar an aber das muss
schneller
es sollte immer jemand hier sein und
schauen dass ständig schnee schmilzt das
ist immer feuer hat
es ist der erste morgen darum lasse ich
das noch durchgehen aber das hier müsste
erste priorität haben und ich gebe euch
noch eine t es ist schön warm rufen kein
schlechter platz wenn du aus dem kalten
zeit kommen
vorsichtig damit ihr nicht die ganze
stunde arbeit zunichte macht
die runde kommen zuerst und dann die
teilnehmer und jede minute verzögerung
am morgen bedeutet weniger tageslicht
während dazu
[Musik]
das müsste immer als erstes machen das
wasser schmelz erst nachher geht er auf
toilette und putz die zähne
der ofen hier muss immer brennen denn
das schmelzen geht lange so als machen
wir noch kaffee dass armin aufwacht
barbara die dreifache mutter ist es die
heute anpackt
[Gelächter]
nur wenig ja
die hunde bekommen rohes fleisch mit
hohem fettgehalt dazu kommen noch
getrocknete protein stücke
an diese routine müssen sich alle erst
gewöhnen denn sie haben die
verantwortung für die tiere
[Musik]
eigentlich wollte juror bereits
unterwegs sein die hunde sind unruhig
sie wollen los
die hunde sind sehr oft geladen sie
wollen rennen ich rechne damit dass
irgendetwas passiert damit alle für den
restlichen tag noch ein team haben
bleibe ich hier um sie allenfalls zu
stoppen
[Musik]
und tatsächlich julius vorahnung
bewahrheitet sich rasch
so hinters bei armin herrscht aufregung
[Applaus]
armins rüden ballack und cooper geraten
in einen kampf
wir hatten hier gerade ein krampf
du musst strenger sein
kann ich immer dazwischen gehen
geh nicht mit den händen rein wenn sie
kämpfen aber sagt stock du bist der chef
es dauert alles solange die hunde werden
nervös ich habe eben zu ihm gesagt dass
er sie nicht streiten lassen da du musst
streng sein wenn du spürst der ton wird
zu aggressiv musst du das sofort stoppen
wenn sie sich für zehn minuten an
brillen kann es aushalten
[Musik]
dann endlich gegen 11 uhr zwei stunden
zu spät geht es los in die zweite etappe
[Musik]
nachdem auch um renommierte
immer tiefer und tiefer in die wildnis
lapplands
[Musik]
die gruppe ist nach der aufregung des
morgens endlich unterwegs
hundeführer yuko hofft dass sich die
huskies beruhigen wenn sie endlich
laufen können
[Musik]
und tatsächlich
friedlich zieht auch das fünfer gespann
des brunnenmeister serbien durch die
abgeschiedenheit finnlands
[Musik]
ihre schlitten haben die fünf schweizer
schon besser im griff jeder führt
proviant und gepäck selber mit bis zu 60
kg
[Musik]
der erste stopp nach wenigen kilometern
und kuba hat sich beim kampf am morgen
verletzt sicherheitshalber nimmt in judo
aus dem bestand
ist sogar schon bis
mittelgroßer hund und lorca will einer
verletzung noch
nicht viel zu sehen
die wunde ist nicht
nur ein kratzer auf der hand
[Applaus]
das an unsere unabhängigkeitstag
am sechsten dezember 1917 löste sich
finnland aus der russischen
vorherrschaft seither ist dieser tag der
finnische nationalfeiertag
judo verabreicht dem verletzten truppe
eine tablette und gönnt dem tier eine
verschnaufpause
[Musik]
ich gebe ihm entzündungshemmende mittel
es ist wirklich nur ein kleiner schnitt
es sieht nicht schlimm aus
ich nehme ihnen meine notfall kiste auf
den schlitten und schauen abend was wir
machen wenn es ihm am morgen nicht
besser geht muss ihn jemand abholt
dass ballack mit ihm reichen noch 400
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit 39 kilo ist ballack der größte hund
aus juris rudel
[Musik]
eishockey 2
immer weiter
[Musik]
weg von der zivilisation
weg von den anforderungen des alltags
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für silvia bedeutet jeder tag eine neue
herausforderung mit ihrer parkinson
krankheit
perfekt wie geht es dir sehen wir gut
das war wohl das schwierigste
streckenabschnitt der ganzen woche
ja ich weiß noch nicht so genau wie ich
mein gewicht einsetzen soll um richtig
zu steuern
michelle die physiotherapeutin kümmert
sich sofort und die hunde
[Musik]
der starke ballack und armin freunden
sich langsam an und werden zum team
und wie geht es kuka im fahrenden
krankenzimmer
wäre einfach zu vorwitzig kuba ist ein
park er ist ein eineinhalbjähriger
flechten
normalerweise haben andere hunde respekt
vor ballack aber der war dumm genug
ballack heraus zu fahren und natürlich
hat er verloren
ist dass sein charakter
coopers noch jung und sucht noch seinen
platz in der hunde hier reichen
christoph sauer
auf sie wartet
gestern mal so ganz klar wie passieren
ich muss sagen 23 kilometer
bin ich verachte emotional wurde weil
einfach so so alles auf mich nicht
erpressen fahrt einfach plötzlich mit
dem eigenen schlitten durch eine
wunderschöne war das funktioniert alles
märz ohne seine firma merkatz federer
ist mich glücklich man ist
völlig losgelöst vor allem also
natürlich umgebungen einiges dazu mit
dass man einfach nicht nicht unbedingt
an alltag dank
und sylvia dass sie viele gruppe
kommt einfach
krank ist aber
völlig es ist ein guter grund sich
hinter
davon immer gewünscht
extrem
ich auch ich vergesse meine parkinson
erkrankung und das ist so wichtig danken
schon gut und ich habe vergessen dass du
diese erkrankung überhaupt wir sind
diesen steilen hügel runter gefahren und
ich habe gedacht ist das wirklich sinn
ich bin eine kämpferin
dieser hügel war anspruchsvoller als
alles was noch kommen wird es kommt zwar
noch größere anstiege aber die sind viel
einfacher aufgeben kommt für mich nicht
in frage das ist die richtige
einstellung
[Musik]
hugo hat wohl aus taktischen gründen
etwas untertrieben mit dem
bevorstehenden anstrengungen vor dem
team liegt ein steiler anstieg über 200
meter es ist gegen 15 uhr und dunkle
nacht
jetzt kommt nochmals ein großer anstieg
dann eine abfahrt wir fahren hoch so
schnell es geht wir stoppten oben nicht
und fahren wirklich langsam ihn und alle
zusammen
[Musik]
naja
frauen haltet die augen offen
[Musik]
die hunde sind stark doch bei so einem
anstieg müssen die teilnehmer mithelfen
sie dürfen dabei ihren schlitten auf
keinen fall verlieren
auch armin bleibt trotz besonders
starkem gespann die anstrengung nicht
erspart
die ehemalige profi bobfahrerin michael
ist voll in ihrem element
[Musik]
aber es ist unglaublich sie konnten das
tempo und verlagen von ge sprach links
und sexy
wellendingen wort ist
die scheibe
[Musik]
iz
armin war nicht immer brunnenmeister er
hatte 30 jahre lang ein sanitär heizungs
geschäft das er vor fünf jahren verkauft
hat um seinem leben eine neue wende zu
geben
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir gewinnen scheiße
um 17 uhr erreichen alle das nachtlager
ohne weitere zwischenfälle
[Musik]
oku ich bin hellauf begeistert langsam
sitzen die handgriffe und die hunde
werden sofort versorgt
die doppelte menge wurst wirklich ja es
war ein langer tag und es wird eine
kalte nacht werden sie brauchen viel
energie und dann füttern wir sie nach
ein bis zwei stunden
barbara ist für dass hundefleisch
zuständig
ich zeige euch wo es wasser gibt wasser
schöpfung geht schneller als schnee
schmelzen es kocht schon
wir holen jetzt mehr wasser wirklich
aber der topf ist heiß
so zeigt silvia wo er eine quelle
entdeckt hat
es gibt ja überall wasser wir müssen nur
klar ist finden
es schmeckt gut sooo lange nicht so viel
dreck im komitee
wir brauchen mehr ja ich habe den großen
behälter auf meinem schlitten einige
davon
es gibt auch eine kleine quelle hier hat
es immer was wir können sogar unser
trinkwasser von dort
dann warten wir
ja der geschmack war gut nicht ehrlich
juho schaut nach dem verletzten kuba
ich bin fast sicher ist am anfang viel
schlimmer aus als es war
ein kleiner schnitt
die verletzung geht nicht lief nicht bis
auf die muskeln oder das fleisch
so lange wir die wunde sauber halten
sollte er morgen laufen können
ich habe keine schmerzmittel gegeben
weil ich wissen wollte ob er schmerzen
hat
mit den medikamenten würde auf jeden
fall auf
willst was an
dieser klavier ist elf jahre alt und
schon locker 30.000 kilometer mit mir
gelaufen
es gibt eine kleine massage für den
alten herren
gegen den steifen wirken
das ist der richtige ort
[Musik]
nach tagen wie diesen freuen sie sich
auf die heiße fleisch suppe
[Musik]
meinst du die hunde kennen ihn schon
ich glaube die hunde gewöhnen sich an
euch
es ist schon der zweite tag sie sind
immer und dieselbe person die ihnen das
fressen gibt
ja bei ihm läuft vieles über das essen
sie funktionieren relativ einfach wir
sie füttert ist für sie quasi gott
morgen läuft es gleich wie heute wir
sollten um 6 oft
denn wir sind etwas langsam und wir
sollten noch effizienter werden nicht
herum trügen
eine person kümmert sich um den kopf für
das hundefutter und bleibt auch dort
eine macht das teewasser und geht nicht
weg
ich nenne jetzt keinen namen aber schaut
wirklich dass ihr kontinuierlich neuen
schnee in den ofen hineinschaut vor dass
die flamme immer groß genug
dass andere das hat selbst mich
die hunde haben eine wahnsinnige
das ist zwar toll wenn es uns rennen
aber vor dem start kann es gefährlich
werden
sie sind so aufgeladen morgen es geht
noch so lange sie an der nacht leine
sind
aber sobald wir ihnen das los
geht der energiepegel hoch
war wahrscheinlich noch nie in einen
streit verwickelt er hat coop angenommen
ich habe nicht gesehen wie es angefangen
hat aber ich bin sicher kuba hat ihn
provoziert und am schluss musste ich ihn
den ganzen tag auf dem schlitten
hinterher 2
passt von jetzt an auf am morgen
ist in ordnung wenn sie mit dem schwanz
wedeln und glücklich sind ist es okay
aber
sobald ihr hört dass der ton ändert wenn
sie aggressiv werden und ihre freunde
muster was machst du wenn sie anfangen
einander an zu schreien und da bildet es
sofort
das ist nicht alles denn in einem
nächsten schritt tritt ja mal verletzt
und wir sind aufgeschlossen die hälfte
des teams bei mir in der notfall box
landet ich jedenfalls
sonst habt ihr es gut gemacht auch das
fahren
die temperatur ist deutlich gefallen es
sind jetzt eisige minus 20 grad
[Musik]
die fünf abenteurer haben schon wieder
verschlafen sie sind fast eine stunde zu
spät dran es ist schon fast 7 uhr
[Musik]
wir machen heute keine lange mittagsrast
denn wir müssen noch im tageslicht den
großen hügel
wir füllen die thermosflaschen und essen
unterwegs
heute steht die königsetappe an mit dem
alles tun um dem höchsten punkt der tour
einem hügel mit einem harten aufstieg
auf 200 metern
es sieht gut aus es ist jetzt etwa halb
neun
das zelt ist mehr geräumt die hunde sind
früher gefüttert worden
ich bin wirklich erfreut über diese
steigen
jetzt muss ich mich mit meinem zelt
bereiten dass ich nicht die lahme ente
bin
auch das anspannen läuft heute schon
viel besser
[Applaus]
und wie geht es der patientin den jungen
punk cooper
er kann heute laufen
ich habe gestern vielleicht etwas
übertrieben
der schnitt weit war so groß
jetzt ist die wunde schon fast
geschlossen kein blut nur eine kleine
verletzung
aber du nimmst du in dein team
ja ich will schauen ob beim nächsten
stopp wirklich steht er liebt es zu
rennen da wird man ihm nichts anmerken
er wird mir vorspiel dass alles gut ist
alles ist heute viel ruhiger als gestern
eine ruhe die auch barbara spürt die
dreifache mutter und psychologin
ach
ja die letzten jahre sind sind schon oft
sehr sie hatten ihren der länder hat
nun
karriere jens stamm und kriegen das
schöne crazy
für ihn vor allem natürlich mit der
zweiten chance
tendenz
ich bin sehr optimistisch dass
die
negative emotionen prozent verdauen
[Musik]
und dann geht es los auf die 40 km
strecke und den alles tun durch zum
schluss der selbst für erfahrene masche
eine herausforderung ist
[Musik]
inzwischen sind sie am dritten tag
unterwegs aber bei bis zu minus 20 grad
in der kälte übernachtet sind bis zu 14
stunden auf den beinen und lassen sich
täglich auf neues und ungewohntes 1
eher durch
[Musik]
langsam runter fahren
b
joghurt sie durch er will den
angekündigten harten anstieg mit den
schweizern unbedingt noch bei tageslicht
erreichen noch bleiben zwei stunden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
deshalb gibt es heute nur eine ganz
kurze pause damit sich die hunde für die
bevorstehenden anstrengungen stärken
können
[Musik]
80 portionen hedgen
segal und
roboter ruft man gestern dass das wenn
du es vorträge ich das nur behinderte
den hof war schon geübt
[Musik]
martina die hr managerin spürt
inzwischen die anstrengung spiel sowie
die
westlb ist eine relativ gut gegangen ich
hatte immer wieder ihres auf bundesbank
sie wurde vom trailer ob er jetzt kam er
über den großen see so viel ich sehe
keinen sinn die flach und das hat mir
während im see fahren zu lassen könnte
mit der kasse wie das funktioniert kurz
vor würden die
hunde kennen keine müdigkeit und weiter
[Musik]
natürlich
nicht
hilfe weg gemacht wirklich nicht machen
[Musik]
damit die huskies auf dem vereisten see
nicht zu schnell werden müssen die
teilnehmer dauernd auf der bremse stehen
[Musik]
nach dem see zieht junge gleich weiter
bereits setzt das dämmerlicht 1
das gelände wird immer unebener seit
vier stunden stehen sie jetzt schon auf
den schlitten ein körperlicher und
koordinative kraftakt für alle
[Musik]
alles in ordnung
nichts passiert
silvia vergiss nicht zu bremsen bist du
eingeschlafen
ich habe schon gebremst ich bin auf der
metallplatte gestanden ja aber du bist
vielleicht schon etwas schläfrig
unterwegs
die bremse benutzen die bremse
das war ein weckruf
[Musik]
erst gegen 15 uhr erreichen sie den
anstieg zur mall ist um durch
fast bei tageslicht
fast wir sind schon weit wie weit nach
jetzt geht es nur noch hoch und dann
sind wir da ein flaches stück mehr von
jetzt darin eine stunde genau
[Musik]
den 200 meter steilen anstieg müssen sie
nun in dunklen befahren was die sache
nicht leichter macht
[Musik]
dieser steile strecken abschnitt gehört
auch zu einem langstreckenrennen das
judo und die anderen schlitten profis
mit ihren hunden bewältigen
[Musik]
nächster schritt ist hier krempel mit
und haben wir verstehen uns leid mit die
hoffnungen machen für die tiere so
stimmt ja noch patiniert bank
geht hier gar krampf das ist wirklich
die gesamte who und der studie freudig
das ist doch eine und der schlitten
offizier das ist wieder
alle haben es geschafft
ich habe trotz müdigkeit packen sie nun
alle an und unterstützen sich
gegenseitig keine spur von chaos und
den
ungebremsten hebt
nach avant und
das warum ist sich schnell einig weise
also wenn ich sagen kann und man ist in
crysis 2 3 liter am tag und ich glaube
die thermosflasche um iran hält man kann
man sich bei wolff und sich nützlich und
so hat man auch ein bisschen
wirkt vertraue ich ihnen es ist der
dritte tag und mit nur wenig ratschläge
funktionieren sie jetzt gut als team
kein grund zur sorge mehr
sie haben richtig festgemacht graben
gleicher für die hunde helfen sich
gegenseitig
jetzt warten wir nur noch bis das essen
fertig ist
lasst sie schlafen
[Musik]
für die alte hundedame jazz gibt es
heute eine willkommene überraschung
statt in der kälte bei minus 20 grad
darf sie im zelt bei den teilnehmern
übernachten
die beziehen
ein glück
[Musik]
6 uhr tagwacht
es ist schnell
spiele die von morgen
coach teile
verkauft
[Musik]
ja also
[Gelächter]
an diesem tag legt die längste tour vor
ihnen über 50 kilometer und nach den
steilen aufstieg von gestern eine
schwierige abfahrt
die abfahrt ist selbst für judo
anspruchsvoll
er sorgt sich um silvia
wie geht es dir zu ehrlich
ich habe besser geschlafen hatte warm
genug
ich glaube
das schaffe ich heute
tue und die hunde müssen einfach sicher
runterkomme
und etwas zu riskieren
du sagst es mir einfach du bist direkt
hinter mir sagt mir wenn du eine pause
braucht
wir versuchen den tag zu genießen
wir müssen uns nicht mehr
im team gibt es eine die sich auf die
lange abfahrt richtig freut die
ehemalige bobfahrerin mich
schnell aber sicher ich glaube zu
erhöhen die sich dem bodengrund aus aber
wichtig dass da nichts passiert
durch die ganze arbeit gemacht
[Musik]
martina dagegen hatte gestern kopfe
ich auch sehr gut schlafen mein hund
minister hat kann vielleicht ist das der
grund warum ich so gut und hat mehr
durchlaufen
und ja heute energie tankt und stoppen
eigentlich gar nicht gesprochen dass man
ein zauberwort alle machen sich bereit
für die abfahrt
barbara stimmt sich auf ihre art ein
[Musik]
armin sorgt sich um die pfoten seiner
hunde ich habe auf waren morgens fest
und wenn's die nsa stammt auch ein
segelflieger das ist
es rum
ich musste da die vielen karl ecker und
sie ist es wichtig ein
blick ins special
das für ein
echter leader die
architekten ist das
totenbett
das ist eine kleine hilfe dass weder der
gruppe noch den hund etwas passiert auf
der langen abfahrt
wenn der fuß von der bremse gerutscht
oder sie sogar runterfallen und die
kontrolle über den schlitten verlieren
dann wirken diese ketten unter den kufen
wie eine starke bremse der schlitten
wird nicht in die hunde hinein
so spielt es keine rolle ob sie runter
fahren
diese ketten hier braucht dass niemandem
etwas passiert
[Musik]
200 meter abfahrt durch bäume zwischen
verschneiten felsen die durch dieses mal
bei tageslicht und hohen truppen
[Musik]
alles was sie bis jetzt gelernt haben
ist nun gefordert und eine gute portion
mut
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das war eine verrückte abfahrt ich hab's
geschafft
er ist vom tag fühlt sich jetzt wie ein
spaziergang an die brems ketten halfen
danke vielmals für deine tipps mit der
gewichtsverlagerung ja nicht
runtergefallen
das war kein einfaches spiel
[Musik]
reporter zeigen und macht so hätte
meeresforscher zeit und und eines hinten
umarmt
sagte schnitzler emotionen aber acht
stolz haben mitgemacht aber es ist wie
wir finden wie sie finden das auch echo
ist auch im beruf
ich erinnere mich noch letztes jahr beim
rennen lappland quest haben sogar die
profis nachher gesagt dieser hügel hätte
sie geschlaucht und die haben jahrelange
erfahrung zehn punkte für alle hier
genießt den rest des tages gut gemacht
die strecke an diesem tag ist noch lang
aber der stress vom anfang ist gewichen
selbst martina die hr managerin die
sonst gerne alles unter kontrolle hat
entdeckt neue seiten an sich
legen wir wissen um was es
ist wird dieser moment vorm abschied
oder die hetze mutmassen
vorstellig essay vorläufig
wenig schön und das sagen auch seine
wiegten
sich eine sehr liebe und
natürlich angst nun geschehen und das
gab der bahn ins feld tanks haben nur
dann quasi bedarf an land
[Musik]
die route führt wieder über den see den
sie erst gestern überquert haben
inzwischen sind die schweizer mit ihren
hunden zu einem team zusammengewachsen
nach zwei stunden fahrt ein stoppsignal
von tour guide juhu davon hatte er der
gruppe nichts verraten
ich passe auf die hunde auf ich mach das
schon legt mir die snacks für die hunde
raus
ich habe keine mehr sie hatten
die leute von der gemeinde pass maria
die haben von unserem abenteuer erfahren
und haben eine kleine überraschung
bereit
[Musik]
ich schau zu den hunden und schicke die
gruppe hinüber zu halten mühle ich habe
so eine ahnung dass sie da etwas feines
erwartet
dass marie ist eine kleine gemeinde
mitten in den wäldern lapplands mit 31
einwohnern verteilt auf 8,3
quadratkilometer am gleichnamigen see
umso größer der stolz darüber den
schweizern ihrer sehenswürdigkeit die
alte mühle zu zeigen wo sie essen und
musik vorbereitet haben
[Musik]
wir haben nur etwas kleines bei euch
noch etwas symbolisches danke vielmals
barbara bittet armin zum tanz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die leute aus bass marie haben
stundenlang lokalen lachs geräuchert die
gruppe erlebt die traditionelle
finnische gastfreundschaft
[Musik]
familie vermisst aber nicht stets
erstaunlich große ziel
kämpft es muss ist das für mich zum
tankstopp und zuarbeit raum und das
wissen das wir ist außer mir weißt ganz
genau dass ich das genießt und das ist
nicht das entscheidende ob es existiert
oder nicht also ich sichere so über sie
haben franziska ritter sport 1 das tor
nicht und
so sind auch die schneehügel mit sich
wenn irgendwie was so eine blöde mit der
hüfte oder ein buch gedruckt und dann
chronisch aber
das ist mir einfach so der
erhalten
wenn wir einfach muskulären
auf wiedersehen wir müssen weiter
vielen dank es war für uns eine sehr
schöne überraschung
zwei uhr nachmittags noch lägen über 30
kilometer in der dunkelheit vor ihnen
[Musik]
die temperaturen liegen bei minus 15
grad
mit über 15 km pro stunde ziehen die
hunde die gruppe durch den wald für sie
gibt es kein halten mehr
dann ein schreckensmoment
beim überqueren der straße werden die
hunde in der dunkelheit fast von einem
bagger überrollt
alles ist noch einmal gut gegangen
[Applaus]
und armin bekommt an diesem tag noch
einmal die geballte kraft seines
hundegespann zu spielen
umgekehrt
[Applaus]
jetzt haben wir den verrücktesten
vorher war auch ein anstieg bei dem ich
für ein paar minuten festsaß und den
schlitten raus zwar wusste aber dieser
hügel ist wirklich steht
wir machen oben sich eine pause und kann
wieder die ketten run zum bremsen und
wir fahren runter zur hütte
seit über sechs stunden unterwegs vor
ihnen liegt der letzte große aufstieg
der tour
[Musik]
abrams hat
noch eine abfahrt
ich wünsche mir dass dieser traum nie
aufhört
ich finde es okay dass das der letzte
anstieg war ja das verstehe ich aber mir
gefällt einfach alles
die crew
das
[Musik]
passiert
ganz bestimmt
die qualität
ich wünsche mir
im moment gedanken
und die freude
das ist für diese
[Musik]
die tage alleine mit den hunden in der
wildnis lapplands neigen sich langsam
dem ende zu
[Musik]
gegen 19 uhr erreichen sie ihren letzten
rastplatz am see
[Musik]
alle haben es durchgestanden die runde
und die abenteuer rennen
das hat sie schon ziemlich
herausgefordert
das war sich am limit
und selbst für mich nicht einfach
sie mussten bestimmte aus ihrer
komfortzone aus
ja ich glaube das hat gestimmt
und wenn die extrem zurück
ich muss gestehen
die der mensch mensch mensch neben pc
und
ich
bewundere die eben aus was sie ihre
energie big names und wenig faszination
ist begeistert denn ist egal wie schwer
das
wachstum bei die machen einfach die kann
einfach straight
ich habe mich definitiv verliert das
kann man so sagen und ich hätte gar
nicht am montag erhöht wenn dem fahrer
kurzen gedanken kaum
eine chance sich helmut zunahme in
jährlich
wahnsinnig innerhalb von vier tagen
bin ich keine zahl aber
so eine liebes beruhen
und daran ist geil
[Musik]
ein letztes mal aufstehen ein letztes
mal ein spannender runde die ihnen ans
herz gewachsen sind und ihnen das
unvergessliche erlebnis ermöglicht haben
[Musik]
jo hat vertrauen in junge hunde gesetzt
etwa in die einjährige mayday und andere
von denen er nicht wusste wie sie das
abenteuer meistern
[Musik]
sie haben sich viel besser gehalten als
ich erwartete
gestern war verrückt aber sie haben
durchgehalten
oft können hunde einen tag lang eine
harte strecke rennen du siehst erst am
nächsten tag zu übertriebenen bis zu
schnell oder zu weit weg
mayday hat alles gefressen am morgen und
am abend
jetzt sieht sie aus als hätte sie gar
nichts gemacht
das war die richtige entscheidung und
auch das richtige tempo ich war
überrascht dass ich sie nicht in die
kiste nehmen musste
das waren mehr als 50 kilometer heute
und einige harte aufstiege es freut mich
wirklich dass meine hunde immer noch so
gut drauf sind
haben wir die girls etwas auf
das ist die richtige stärke
was bedeutet dir deine hunde
das werde ich viel gefragt und die
antwort ist immer noch nicht einfach
es ist ein mix zwischen einem haustier
und einem sport kollegen
wie in einem sport team
manchmal habe ich das gefühl ich bin der
coach sie die athleten oder die kollegen
aber
im nachtlager sind sie dann eher wie
tiere für die ich sage es kommt drauf an
aber ich würde sie trotzdem nicht
einfach als haustier bezeichnet mit
denen macht man nicht so etwas
verrücktes man wirft ihnen auf dem sofa
einen ball zu
ich glaube eigentlich sind sie
teamkollegen du schaffst es das kennt
oder kommt diese hügel nicht hoch aber
sie brauchen dich auch für das essen
dass du für sie so horst
jetzt könnt ihr euch etwas entspannen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für eine kurze zeit aus den
verpflichtungen des alltags ausbrechen
[Musik]
fünf menschen die sich nicht gekannt
haben sind zu einem team geworden
[Musik]
sie mussten lernen sie mussten sich
überwinden sie mussten kämpfen und sie
haben alle etwas gewonnen zeit
[Musik]
zeit wieder einmal zu spüren wer sie
sind und was sie wollen in der weite und
der ruhe lappland
[Musik]
und so endet dieses abenteuer dort wo es
vor fünf tagen begonnen hat auf der
ranch von jura
[Musik]
mit fünf menschen die ihrem leben ein
neues kapitel hinzugefügt haben
[Musik]
und fremde zu freunden gemacht hat
denn manchmal ist es an der zeit das zu
tun wovon man immer geträumt hat
[Musik]
abendland präsentiert von conti kreise
ein spezialist für den es in nord konnte
krieg punkt ch